the Republicans won the Senate where
they appoint judges the Dems took the
house where they fix parking tickets but
the real chumps those who rejected due
process Republicans unseated for
senators Heitkamp McCaskill Donnelly
bill Nelson all known for what leading
the mob tried to destroy justice Brett
Kavanaugh I wanted you to hear directly
from me about why I'm voting against
confirmation of Judge Cavanaugh I think
that vote against Cavanaugh was going to
be tough no matter what I voted against
judge Cavanaugh because of concerns
about his impartiality I will vote no on
judge Cavanaugh yep four out of the six
vulnerable Senate Democrats in Trump
land lost Jon Tester who voted against
Cavanaugh barely squeaked it out the one
who refused the accusatory bait and
voted for Cavanaugh joe Manchin he won
this is good news it shows that many
Americans saw which trial unfold before
their very eyes and they didn't shrug it
off it's true that the two biggest
mobsters Feinstein and crazy Maisy did
fine in the land of sunstroke and
fish-paste but for the rest their
cowardly actions had consequences four
people lost their jobs so maybe the next
time they're asked asked to play fair
Democrats might fear for their careers
before destroying in others sure be nice
that they didn't resort to such horrible
tactics because they're good people
but they're politicians on the
evolutionary table of people we admire
you'll find nurses at the top and
politicians at the bottom they do what
they do out of desire for power so if
they can't understand right and wrong
maybe they'll understand moving their
crap out in boxes do you think that in
effect Dana absolutely do we should say
Nelson is going to exist for a recount
and say yes of course I believe he's
going to lose that's my prediction
McCaskill actually declared that she
would vote against Cavanaugh before the
doctor for delegate right forward right
so she didn't even give him a chance on
that I also feel like Senator Chuck
Schumer made a mistake I don't know if
you remember how brilliant I was at back
in August and I said why don't they just
the Democrats would just cave early
because he's going to get confirmed
instead of dragging this out just let
the red state Democrats vote for
Cavanaugh and move on and focus on
health care or whatever but instead they
had to have this moment and it backfired
they should have believed in I can't
believe the Democrats too
take political advice from Fox News you
think they would really listen so the
question is you're right they made a
mistake but are they gonna repeat the
same mistake and I think they probably
will I want to take this opportunity to
talk about how bad the polls were NBC
News look how bad they botched this they
were eight points off in Indiana nine
points off in Missouri
seven points off in Arizona and I could
go down the list worst poll I've ever
seen in a midterm election in these
Senate's race I could go on and on also
look at these approval numbers for
president Trump in crucial states
Michigan he's at 45 PA 45 Wisconsin 47
Florida 51% Ohio 52% those are really
good approval rating numbers going into
2020 and if people think that you know
this was a blue wave this was nothing
oh stop and who won the governor's race
[Laughter]
you know what is interesting to me going
back to poll numbers I'm looking at poll
numbers on Cavanaugh was Cavanaugh's the
vote on Cavanaugh very important guess
what 42% of Republicans say was very
important to them but 55% of the
Democrats say it was very important to
them because they hate to process they
don't hate to project gave the guy due
process that was not deprive didn't get
due process Merrick garland so his life
ruined please so what's a Gary not due
process
Carl is a martyr to the demo you didn't
parade his family in front of a group of
judges God for that played unfair play
brutal politics in you guys say all
right that's all right Manchin you know
in the polls right before the election
they said if would you vote for him if
he had voted no on Cavanaugh and people
said no I wouldn't
so the polls have been really all over
the place on a Cavanaugh issue because
some of the ones that we got late
yesterday also indicated that it was a
more positive for Democrats than it was
positive for Republicans but that's not
what we saw play out in with with
Donnelly either
and it's interesting Donnelly said oh
but I
had nothing to do with with the whole
dr. Ford thing it was just because he's
impartial so you know Democrats were all
over the map in the cabin it was
outraged so many people I think just in
terms of the issue of wanting a fair
process yeah you know that's what it
really got back to I think for so many
people and you look at something that
has is such an old old allegation
without enough corroboration and they
just don't want to see someone be hurt
for that because it's not provable at
that point in the situation that's
something that I think people feel very
deeply and I do think it had a major
impact on the Senate